[Musique]
c'est cela la soirée complète
ces refus sont invités à une soirée
compote complot brutus
cki césar pour toi si l'on perd or ça
suffit avec tous ternois c'est pas parce
que j'ai mis ta mère enceinte que je
suis ton père antonia vous voulez tuer
ses heures il y à un endroit où il est
vulnérable
la carotide non c'est au sénat qu'il est
vulnérable puisque à la carotide sétois
brutus qui aura l'honneur de frapper en
premier je pourrais écrire un truc genre
liberté c'est pas possible ça je suis
sûr de lui
ton fils de rejoint l'ennemi
il semble très proche d'une benoit tu
vas tuer ce traître je te donne deux
mille hommes les attends je vais donner
ce que je peux pour l'autre en tant
qu'esclave ton cerveau est pas adapté tu
peux pas comprendre ce que je dis pas
franchement là j'ai tout compris
non non
[Musique]
elle te plaît al banna un peu frais du
match wahou a été touché et dégoûté
aussi je fais d'un point de vue
gastrique c'est fou
[Applaudissements]
une porsche toute neuve il me mélange le
blanc et le rouge donc est happé par les
douze coups de fouet sur la touche maj
ht de chiffre